- Here's a legal pro tip.
If you admit to opposing counsel
that he's having a Perry Mason moment
while cross-examining you...
- If this is your Perry Mason moment-
- Well, you're probably screwed,
and that is exactly what
happened to Alex Jones.
Alex Jones got so skewered
on cross-examination
that the writers of "Law & Order" said
it was too unrealistic for the show.
Now, to say that this defamation trial
by some of the Sandy Hook
families against Alex Jones
is going poorly for Jones
is quite the understatement.
Now, to recall how we got here,
Jones is already in hot water.
This trial is only over damages,
how much Jones is going to
have to pay these families,
because he and his lawyers engaged
in so many discovery abuses
that the judge sanctioned him,
gave him effectively terminating sanctions
where he had to concede liability.
Jones lost the case,
and the Sandy Hook
plaintiffs won by default.
That's how abusive they
were during discovery.
But that takes us to the viral video
that you might have seen clips of
where the plaintiffs'
attorney, Mark Bankston,
absolutely destroys Alex Jones on cross
after just setting him
up for a gigantic fall.
So let's take a look.
- [Mark] One of the things
you talked about yesterday
is you complied with discovery, right?
You said that on the witness stand.
- That's one of the things I talked about.
- I mean, Jones did not
actually comply with discovery,
but I guess now they're saying
after all the sanctions,
they have upheld all of their obligations.
- [Mark] One of the things
that you were ordered
to do in this lawsuit, you were ordered
to turn over any text messages
mentioning Sandy Hook.
Right?
- Yes.
- Yeah, so probably the very first request
that the plaintiffs would've
made is any documents
that mention the phrase Sandy Hook
or refer to the events of Sandy
Hook that Jones possesses.
This is discovery 101.
These are the kind of
requests you're going to make.
- [Mark] And you didn't have any, right?
- Not that we could find.
- Now, that's a bit of a cop-out by Jones.
He's saying, "You know,
I might've had them,
but we couldn't find them."
That doesn't get out of his obligations
because you have to do a reasonable search
and your lawyers have to make sure
that you do a reasonable search
to find responsive documents.
- [Mark] And you, in fact,
told me in your testimony,
sworn testimony, before
coming to this courtroom.
You searched, right?
- I did.
- Okay.
- All right, so Bankston has set this up.
"You've testified that you didn't have
any Sandy Hook-related texts and that,
of course, you did a search for them."
It's all downhill from here for Jones.
- [Mark] Do you remember...
Were you here for Mr. Shroyer's testimony?
- Yes.
- Okay.
Do you remember when Owen
said, "The company has learned
from its mistakes about Sandy Hook?"
Do you remember that?
- Oh. I did hear him say that.
- [Mark] Do you agree with that?
- Yeah, we certainly
learned from our mistakes.
Got a lot better.
- Okay.
- Mr. Jones, I'd like to
show you what's been marked
as plaintiff's exhibit 130.
You've got it upside down.
That's text messages between
you and Paul Watson, isn't it?
- Yes.
- And they mention Sandy Hook, don't they?
- Yeah.
- Plaintiffs move 130 into evidence.
- All right, so this is the kind of stuff
you'd never see in movies.
It's the meat and potatoes of litigation.
It's kinda the boring stuff.
You're laying a foundation
that this document is
what it purports to be,
this witness has verified it,
and then you're moving it into evidence.
But so far, seems pretty routine.
We're about to find out
why that is not the case,
and it is a brilliant act
of setting everyone up
for a fall here.
- [Judge] Any objections?
- The judge asks, "Any objections?"
No. Why would there be any objections?
This is probably just one of the millions
of documents that were turned over.
- No. No objections.
- [Judge] Plaintiff's 130 is admitted.
- No objection.
So the opposing counsel
doesn't quite understand
what this document is at this point,
and so he waives any
objection he might make
to entering this particular
document into evidence.
Now Jones has been screwed.
- Let's zoom in on the little
article up in the corner.
I'm gonna walk over to this
to you so I can kinda point.
I know it's a little hard to read.
You might be able to read it a
little better on your screen.
But this is a zoom of...
Mr. Watson has sent you a
screenshot from infowars.com.
Correct?
- Appears to be.
- Yeah, and it has an article here.
Right?
- Yeah.
- And it says "Staged?
Video Shows Hospital
Using Dummies in ER for
Coronavirus Footage."
- [Alex] I believe so.
- [Mark] Let's go to the
first message from Mr. Watson.
Read along with me, Mr. Jones.
He says, "This is a video"-
- Sorry, excuse me one second.
- No problem. Take your time.
- Man, Jones has a nasty cough.
I guess he needs to take
more of those supplements
that he hawks on his channel.
- You may not think it's a
problem, but it's a real one.
- [Mark] Sure.
Mr. Watson says, "This is a video
of a medical student training to intubate.
Makes us look ridiculous,
suggesting this means COVID is fake.
Sandy Hook all over again."
Did I read that correctly?
- Yes.
- [Mark] This is the next message.
What'd you tell Mr. Watson?
- "I get it."
- What has happened
is this is something that has taken place
after all of the Sandy
Hook-related communications.
One of his employees says that
"we shouldn't publish this
because it makes us look stupid
and it's evocative of what happened
during the Sandy Hook stuff,"
and Jones says, "I get it."
Everything Jones has said up until now
is basically a lie, and it also shows
that Jones and his attorneys
never actually searched
for responsive communications.
So being caught in that particular lie
and falsity is gonna be much, much worse
than if they had just
turned over these documents
in the first place,
and that is why you comply with discovery.
But let's see how the knife gets twisted.
- [Mark] Mr. Jones, it's true
that this article is right
now live on infowars.com.
I can pull it up. Right?
- I've never seen this text message.
I guess you guys got Paul's.
My phone didn't save 'em,
so that's fine with me.
- [Mark] Your phone didn't
save this text message?
- I told you guys, I
gave it to the lawyers,
who said they drained the phone
and didn't find that stuff.
I don't have my phone.
- Yeah, and now he's trying
to throw his lawyers under the bus.
"That must not have been on my phone.
I searched my phones,
and I turned stuff over to the lawyers.
If you didn't have this,
it's because of the lawyers."
That's not gonna go as planned.
- [Mark] You gave it to the lawyers?
They were supposed to find it?
So that's what your testimony is?
- No, I searched it as well.
I don't know who this one's taken from.
I mean, I just, I turned the phone over
and said to take the stuff off.
- [Mark] Can I have you
look in the very bottom,
below the very bottom left corner?
Is that your phone number?
- Yes.
So you did get my text messages.
You said you didn't.
Nice trick. (stammers)
- [Mark] (chortles)
Yes, Mr. Jones. Indeed.
- The lawyer can't help himself
because he knows what the
next question is going to be.
Alex Jones is trying to
run this really fine line
where yes, he held stuff back.
He got sanctioned so badly
that he lost the liability
phase of the trial.
He thinks it's safe to say, "Well,
I couldn't have possibly held it back
if you have all of these text messages."
But now the final phase
of the trap is just about to be sprung.
- [Mark] You didn't give
this text message to me.
You don't know where this came from.
Do you know where I got this?
- No.
- 12 days ago, your attorneys messed up
and sent me an entire digital copy
of your entire cell phone
with every text message you've sent
for the past two years and, when informed,
did not take any steps to
identify it as privileged
or protected in any way,
and as of two days ago,
it fell free and clear into my possession,
and that is how I know you
lied to me when you said
you didn't have text
messages about Sandy Hook.
Did you know that?
- I told you the truth.
This is your Perry Mason moment.
I gave them my phone and then-
- [Judge] Mr. Jones, you
need to answer the question.
- No, I-
- Did you know this happened?
- So normally, there's
some professional courtesy
amongst lawyers where you're not going
to just absolutely destroy them
and throw them under the bus.
Here, the lawyer is throwing Jones
and his attorneys under the bus.
I've never heard of
something this inflammatory
coming out against
another opposing attorney
during the course of a trial.
The lawyer screwed up
and sent an entire copy
of Jones's phone to opposing counsel
and then didn't claw it back.
There are a million things that you can do
to claw that back.
The lawyer didn't do that.
As a result, Alex Jones is on the stand
just getting destroyed,
being shown that everything
he's talked about is a lie,
that they tried to continue
to hide information from the plaintiffs,
and it's only because of
this inadvertent disclosure
that they finally got the documents
that they had been entitled
to this entire time.
The jury is hearing all of this,
and they're finding out how much of a liar
and a fabulist Alex Jones is,
if they didn't know already,
but also that there are
shenanigans as well.
And during the course of trial,
not only the witness's credibility
but the lawyer's
credibility is everything,
and once you lose that credibility,
you're probably screwed,
because the jury will find ways
to award people that they believe
and punish people who they don't believe.
Oh, and by the way, it's
of course impossible
to prep a witness like Alex Jones
to be an effective advocate
on the stand, but man,
you gotta know just the
basics of self-preservation.
Don't tell the cross-examining attorney
that this is his Perry Mason moment.
It kinda signals to the jury
that you're getting screwed
and you deserve to be screwed.
- No, I don't know how
this happened, but I mean,
I told you I gave him my phone
over and you just said no.
- Just answer the question.
- [Mark] You said in your deposition
you searched your phone.
You said you pulled down the texts
and did the search
function for Sandy Hook.
- I have several different
phones with this number,
but I did, yeah.
Of course I...
I mean, that's why you got it.
- There's all kinds of things
that can go wrong in discovery,
but the easiest, the
absolute easiest thing
that you can do as a client
or as a lawyer is to do a word search,
and when the entire trial revolves
around the phrase Sandy Hook,
the absolute bare minimum,
the necessary thing that you have to do,
is do a word search for Sandy Hook.
And it's very clear
that if they had done
this absolute minimum,
fundamental thing, this
text would've been found
and it would've been turned
over to the other side.
But they clearly didn't do that.
- [Mark] No, Mr. Jones,
that's not what happened.
- My lawyer sent it to you,
but I'm hiding it. Okay.
- Mr. Jones, please just answer questions.
There's no question.
Mr. Bankston, also, only ask questions.
- [Mark] Sure.
- And a little bit of foreshadowing here,
this is really underselling what happened
between the two lawyers.
That the opposing counsel,
the defense attorney,
Reynal, sent the full copy
of Jones's phone is just
the tip of the iceberg.
He actually sent way, way more than that
to opposing counsel, effectively probably
the entire case file from the
defense to the plaintiffs.
Just absolute malpractice,
and we're gonna get to that,
because that is, if you can believe it,
even juicier than this
cross-examination is indicating.
- [Mark] Mr. Jones, in
discovery, you were asked,
"Do you have Sandy Hook text
messages on your phone?"
And you said no, correct?
- I mean, if I was
mistaken, I was mistaken,
but you've got the messages right there.
- [Mark] You know what perjury is, right?
I just wanna make sure you
know before we go any further.
Do you know what it is?
- Yes, I do.
I mean, I'm not a tech guy.
I told you I gave, in my testimony,
the phone to the lawyers
before or whatever,
and so you got my phone, but
we didn't give it to you.
- [Mark] Please remember, if you need
to assert the Fifth Amendment, you can.
I need you to know you can do that.
- Ouch. Ouch.
- [Mark] But you testified
under oath previously
that you personally searched your phone
for the phrase Sandy Hook
and there were no messages.
You said that under oath.
- Yes.
- [Mark] And you lied when you said it.
- No, I did not lie.
- And here, the plaintiffs' attorney
is kind of gilding the lily a little bit.
He has now absolutely
established that Jones said
he did a search for the words Sandy Hook
and that he previously testified
that he did not have any
of those communications,
which we now know is
absolutely not the case.
Jones tries to backpedal by
saying, "Look, I was mistaken.
I had many phones, but I thought
that was true at the time."
But that seems extraordinarily unlikely
under the cross-examination
that we just saw,
because, again, you're trying
to impugn the witness's character
and show that the witness is a liar.
So as Mr. Bankston has done here,
you teed up with a prior
inconsistent statement
and then show them either the evidence
or the prior statement
that is contradictory
to what they previously testified to.
So when I saw this clip,
I was flabbergasted.
How in the world did this happen?
How did these documents
get turned over after years
of being hidden by Alex
Jones and his attorneys?
Well, luckily, the court
held a full hearing
on this matter to discuss.
Jones's counsel finally
moved for a mistrial
the day after this testimony came out.
Now, this hearing did not go well.
So let's dive into this hearing,
because from a seasoned litigator,
I think this is actually
even more interesting
than the original cross-examination.
So Jones's attorney is
asking for a mistrial.
Effectively, he's saying
that the malfeasance
from the other side is
so terrible that we need
to end this trial and do it over again.
So how in the world did this happen?
Well, let's hear it
straight from Andino Reynal,
the defense attorney's, mouth.
- A couple weeks before trial,
a file transfer link was sent
to the plaintiffs' attorneys,
specifically Mr. Bankston.
That link linked up a lot of files
that shouldn't have been connected to it.
- Okay, so he's saying
that a link was sent,
probably a Dropbox link,
containing some documents
that needed to be turned
over to the plaintiffs.
Apparently that link contained much,
much more than was intended.
- He said, "I take it
this was sent in error,"
and I responded to him and I said,
"It has been sent in error.
Please disregard the link.
I will work on preparing a new one."
- Okay, so we hear from
the defense attorney
that the plaintiffs'
attorney did notify him
that the production had been made
and it was probably in error.
That's super bad news
for the defense attorney
because if you've been notified
and you don't do anything to claw it back,
well, then you're probably screwed,
which, spoiler, is what happens here.
- I mean, we have a
situation here which is akin
to me mistakenly giving
him the key to a room,
and, you know, he opens
the door to the room,
and instead of finding
what he expected to find,
he sees other doors.
And he recognized that and told me,
"I don't think you meant
to give me this key."
And I said, "Please throw it away."
Apparently, at some point thereafter,
he said, "You know what?
I'd kinda really like to see
what's behind those doors."
- This is an interesting argument,
and he's doing probably a good job
of trying to paint the plaintiffs' actions
in the worst possible light,
because that's what you're gonna need
to convince the judge to claw
back all of these documents.
He's saying that the plaintiffs' attorney
abused the inadvertent production
when rummaging around in
all of these documents
and found what was good for his case
and I guess didn't notify
or destroy the documents
once they were in his possession.
- And that's why we're
here seeking protection
under the Texas Rules of Civil Procedure
as well as the court's
confidentiality order.
- So here's the relief
that the defense attorney is looking for.
He's asking for a protective order
to stop disseminating the documents,
to claw them back, to assert privilege,
and to destroy those documents
that have been inadvertently
turned over to the plaintiffs.
- You're right.
I'm just gonna start
unsending these one by one.
- You wrote, "Unsend."
You keep sending the word unsend.
"Unsend, unsend, unsend.
Please do not read.
I'm begging you."
- I hate to be put into this position
by the conduct of plaintiffs' counsel.
- And of course he is trying
to blame plaintiffs' attorney
for this mess, not he himself,
the one that inadvertently
produced all this stuff.
- And that's why, in
addition to the request
that they delete the
information from their servers
and delete the link, we're also requesting
at this point, unfortunately, a mistrial.
- And now we hear from
the plaintiffs' attorney
and hear his side of it.
- First, let me just go through
the facts of their side.
This link of materials was sent to me.
It was sent to Mr. Ogden.
It was sent by Mr.
Reynal's legal assistant.
- Ah, okay, so this link was sent
not by defense attorney Andino Reynal
but actually by his legal assistant.
I think that legal assistant
has probably been fired.
An easy mistake to make,
but it's a mistake that
you absolutely cannot make.
- As I informed Mr. Reynal,
we started downloading those materials.
I was busy on trial prep.
I told my paralegal,
"Get these on our server.
Download everything now." All right?
A little bit after he gets
this stuff downloading,
he's like, "Wait a second.
This file that we now have on our server
has clogged up our entire server.
It's, like, 300 gigs.
What's going on?"
- Okay, so the plaintiffs' lawyer
does what probably anyone would do.
You get a link, and you
start downloading it.
And then only once you've
started downloading it
do you realize that it's a
huge production, 300 gigabytes,
and you probably don't
know what's in that link
until you've downloaded everything,
but it's so big that it's
actually clogging his servers,
which is hilarious.
Well, not for Jones's attorneys, though.
- Mr. Reynal actually (indistinct),
so I know he knows how to read it,
but he still hasn't done it.
At the moment, he is up
here requesting a mistrial
because he hasn't followed the rule.
Even today, (indistinct)
has not followed the rule.
The rule requires that production is...
Any privilege is waived.
- Okay, this is easy to miss,
but this is the most important part.
The plaintiffs' attorney
is referring to briefing.
He's saying that the defense's
brief is citing a part
of the Texas Rule of Civil Procedure
about inadvertent
disclosure, and he's saying,
"I know that opposing counsel,
the defense attorney, is able to read,
because he is citing to the operative part
of the Texas Rule of Civil Procedure,
but it actually is
very, very bad for him,"
and he talks about the actual standard.
What happens when you make
an inadvertent disclosure?
Lawyers write these rules,
so obviously they're gonna make it
so that if you inadvertently
disclose something,
there's a way to get it back.
- Any privilege is
waived if within 10 days,
or if you order a shorter
time, but within 10 days,
the producing party of when
they actually discover,
so 10 days from the moment I told him,
that they identify
specifically the material
or information produced and
state the privilege asserted.
I have not heard any privilege.
I have never heard a privilege
asserted over any document.
- So the plaintiffs' lawyer points out
that he notified opposing
counsel of the disclosure.
Opposing counsel didn't do anything.
He didn't supplement his production.
He never asserted privilege.
That means all of these documents,
all 300 gigabytes of
documents, are fair game,
and the plaintiffs'
lawyer is probably right.
- But even more important than that
is all of the stuff in there,
he cannot now come into court and claim
2.3 gigabytes of phone material
blanket designation of confidentiality.
The protective order prohibits that.
You must identify specifically
the documents that are,
and things like Mr. Jones
and his intimate messages
with Roger Stone are not confidential.
- And then the plaintiffs' lawyer explains
that the defense not only failed
to uphold their obligations under 193.3,
but they didn't comply with
the court's protective order.
The court can put in additional rules
that govern the disclosure of information.
They didn't follow that.
They didn't supplement their production,
so even the email that says
"Please disregard that link,
I'll send you another link,"
he didn't even follow through with that.
And oh, by the way, the vast majority
of these documents are not privileged
and should've been disclosed
years and years ago.
- So I don't think that you have complied
with the protective order.
I will let you do so now
if there are documents and you would like
to mark them as confidential,
and we can go through the process
and I can review them and make a decision,
but I'm not going to
seal the entire quantity
of information without
knowing what's in it
when the rules weren't followed properly.
- It's a tremendous amount
of information, Your Honor.
- I know.
The problem is it probably
should've been disclosed
a year ago or longer, and then
there would've been plenty
of time to look through all of it.
- And in the end, the judge
doesn't seal these documents.
She allows the defense to
try to assert privilege.
She recognizes that the vast majority
of these documents are not privileged
and should've been turned over.
And then, of course, the
defense's prior discovery abuses
come back to bite them again
because how in the world are they going
to actually assert privilege
or review 300 gigabytes worth
of files in a couple
of days while at trial?
But the judge doesn't have any sympathy.
She says that this stuff
should've been turned over
and the reason that
they're in this position
is because of their own malfeasance.
And the lesson here that clients learn
time and time again is
don't hold back discovery,
don't engage in discovery abuses,
or stuff like this is going to happen.
Oh, and one more thing.
At the end of the trial,
the plaintiffs' lawyer
lets the judge and opposing counsel know
that law enforcement is
requesting these documents,
and not only law enforcement,
but in particular, the January 6 committee
is very interested in these documents,
and he's going to turn them
over to that committee.
So it looks like that
is just the beginning
of Alex Jones's legal
worries, and you'll be able
to read all about Alex
Jones's future civil
and criminal legal issues
in today's sponsor,
Morning Brew, because
that's my favorite way
to catch up with pop culture and the news.
I've actually been subscribed
to Morning Brew for forever.
It's one of my absolute
favorite newsletters,
and I'm thrilled to tell you why,
because Morning Brew, if
you didn't already know,
is a free daily newsletter
delivered Monday through Sunday.
It gets you up to speed
on business, finance,
tech, and the law in just five minutes,
and it provides a fantastic quick survey
of the most important
issues while being witty,
irreverent, and informative,
and did I mention it's completely free?
This week, I learned
all about Brittney Griner's
nine-year sentence in Russia,
zombie pigs who were brought to life,
no, that's not about Alex Jones,
and Nancy Pelosi landing in Taiwan.
It's basically exactly the mix of news
that I'm actually interested in,
and it's all the stuff
that I didn't even know
that I wanted to know about.
And it's all written in a hilarious style.
Morning Brew is one of the few emails
that I actually open every single day.
So, LegalEagles, this one
is a complete no-brainer.
Morning Brew is completely free
and it takes less than
15 seconds to subscribe.
Just click on the link
that's onscreen right now
or in the description to
get Morning Brew for free,
and not only will you get a newsletter
that you'll actually read,
you'll actually help
out this channel, too.
So click on the link below to
get Morning Brew right away.
And after you sign up, you should click
on this playlist over here
to watch more LegalEagle,
or I'll see you in court.